let's talk about this while they are
accusing Donald Trump of instigating
January 6. we have new evidence as to
who actually was behind January 6. and
it was ladies and gentlemen Joe Rogan
that's right Ray Epps's attorney
responds to allegations of Klein's
involvement January 6. he said the
absurdity of the conspiracy theory does
not stand in the way of it being spread
and weaponized to harm right if Mr Rogan
is truly interested in focusing on who
instigated the attack on the capital he
would find more truth looking at the
mirror than he does in focusing on a
wedding venue owner from Arizona so
basically my eyes must have lied to me
on January 6th when I witnessed Ray Epps
whispered Orion Sampson and the barriers
went down it must have actually been Joe
Rogan doing the whisper in that day Ray
apps is on camera yelling at people to
go into the capital he's on camera and
then he's on the front holding the Trump
thing as the Bears are torn down well I
don't know he was ramming cops he was
holding a barrier that eventually ended
up ramming cops a huge Trump sign that
they picked up sideways
officers what that means I can tell you
that the dude told people to go in the
building and that is on the front line
when they breached the capitol grounds
that's enough well and then I remember
seeing him multiple times throughout the
day on the initial breach you know in
the secondary breach I mean right as
everything really hit the fan that's
when he backed off he just backed off
and kind of faded away into the crowd
and just watched it all take place so I
don't know a clear instigation proves
that he's a Fed a lot of people think he
is but I do think it's absolutely
fascinating that the lawyer is trying to
say that Joe Rogan in any way instigated
January 6 when Rogan's never even had
Trump on his podcast and he refuses to
have Trump on his podcast from what I'm
aware of I don't know I don't know I
don't know if that's I think that's the
media exaggerating I think it's more
like Joe doesn't probably doesn't care
all that much
I mean he already has what the largest
podcast in the entire none either so he
wanted to have him on early early on
2019 or something and then I've heard
that he doesn't he's kind of given up
he's like I'm not I'm not getting
involved with that I don't know it feels
like after the Spotify deal it's a
different show yeah absolutely free
Spotify it was like the craziest Alex
Jones ever and now post Spotify it's
people he finds interesting and wants to
hang out with and just talk to it seems
like he he was able to like with the
guaranteed Revenue stream just make the
show about the conversations he wants to
have
but I digress this is the narrative that
they that they push right in the
indictment against Donald Trump they say
he was spreading false narratives what
they're really saying is he spread a
narrative that defied the corporate
press
what they're saying here now is Joe
Rogan speaks a narrative that defies the
corporate press therefore you are the
enemy you are their enemy and you're the
one causing all the problems
the solution of course I think is
cultural anyone that pushes back gets
thrown into the basket of deplorables
anyone that doesn't totally accept the
official narrative you're cast into the
into the the Trump supporting racist
bigot you know misogynist sexist but you
know the woman that works it works but
at the same time I think it's going to
reach a point because it's happening so
much more consistently with people that
are clearly not Trump supporters aren't
you know right-wing fascists or what
they're being labeled that you're
throwing so many people that don't
qualify into this basket that eventually
the basket is going to be too full and
you're going to be outnumbered because
they're turning on their own in a lot of
these cases also if enough people speak
out against the corporate media at the
same time their people don't get grabbed
it's only when like they'll go after and
it's easy to go after individuals after
a couple weeks go by you're like all
right that one guy made too much noise
about it on Tuesday but like if if
everyone's or enough people are just
launching about the obvious fraudulents
or or mistakes and things it's this is
what I'm saying about culture if the
culture is you get a million views on
Tick Tock and YouTube when you insult
Joe Biden Joe Biden loses the election
that's the culture needs to be built
that's why they employ these like young
gen Z influencers well and they also
allow the left-wing influencers on and
then immediately remove the right wing
influencers from what I've seen I mean I
had a tick tock it was like 260 000
followers it's strikes
band yeah it's not but it may have
launched a new one though it's not just
the political people like Ronnie Radke
just got his Tick Tock uh Ronnie Radke
is the singer of being called uh Falling
in Reverse
um and they're great massive massive he
got he got banned he just got his Tick
Tock band because he was making talking
about trans people and I'm not sure
exactly what he said I didn't I don't
have the uh the stuff in front of me
transcript
well I mean I don't he was he was
talking about trans people
um I don't know what like I said I don't
know what he said but and they they
banned him and like I said this guy I
mean he is fairly like controversial in
the in the rock and heavy metal World in
that he's he's he you know he's a rock
rock star you know I mean he I think he
threw a mic stand into the crowd one
time and he gets into beef with people
on Twitter and and you know he doesn't
do what he's quote unquote supposed to
do but they you know they they booted
him off of uh off of tick tock and and
that's he's not a political guy he just
said something that was Politically
Incorrect it sounds a lot like the guy
sitting right next to me I'm well I mean
I've said some things a rock singer
that's Ronnie Radke's description on uh
falling in reverse.com yeah I'm waiting
to Google your name and and see uh you
know the right wing label slapped on
your Wikipedia oh well I don't know
about my Wikipedia But if you go to any
of the metal blogs most of them yeah
I've seen I've seen those articles yeah
they don't like me and I don't care
because they're scum I've never had a
tick tock anecdotally I don't I don't
hate people involved in the Chinese
Communist party it's a little concerning
to have a uniparty dictating Central
planning of a system
um I don't hate those people I will
never use I should maybe Never Never Say
Never but I have no interest in using
that uh manipulative trash Tick Tock but
you look at you look at the massive
reach though Tick Tock the amount of
views they bring in it blows other
platforms and anybody can go viral
that's that's the nice thing about Tick
Tock but the right needs to use that
that's a sad reality of it you need the
ride on Tick Tock you need their ideas
because that's where young kids I mean
that's that's what they do all day they
just sit up and swipe it doesn't say a
on your Wikipedia page that you're right
wing but it does smear you pretty bad it
says that you're a fan of Taylor Swift I
you know
sometimes sometimes the internet uh gets
something right you know yeah it just
says that you're you're a recurring
guest on this show and you're a
Libertarian or something that's cool
moved to New Hampshire to join the
libertarian movement so when you said
everyone's got to use the or you got to
use tick tock to get through to the
people I feel like that's like saying
here if we were in a war or something
you're like here use the enemy's weapons
that are tracking your every move
because they're better weapons yeah but
you're going to be tracked regardless
look at Instagram look at Twitter I mean
all these are data harvesting companies
you're tracked no matter what you have
an electronic device in your pocket at
all times you know the tick tock isn't
going to track you any better than all
these other apps that are harvesting
it's the CCP I don't want the CCP to be
tracking me yeah I think I might be the
least of your worries though or the CCP
right like your own government has been
weaponized against you right now they're
the ones you should be worried about of
course CCP is a threat I don't know I
mean much more threatening the Chinese
communist part is much more threatening
to the American civilians I agree and
you don't want to be on Tick Tock
because this idea that you join Tick
Tock for the purpose of engaging in that
conflict perhaps makes sense to a
certain degree but we want to force the
conversation onto the platforms where we
have more control yeah I can agree with
that but at the same time Tick Tock you
can transfer those you know your
audience off of that to the necessary
actually really that's why they ban you
yeah well Tick Tock that was my hardest
thing is you know I had 260 000
followers but it was the actual return
rate to your other platforms but if you
gather enough followers you get enough
engagement you do get a little bit of
return rate there but you also want to
make sure you're on pla on these
platforms so you can push back to the
extent you're able to push back well
there's upsides and downsides of course
to it all but I think in the end you
know it would be beneficial for the
right at least to have some sort of
presence on the app yeah the only
problem with having Tick Tock is like
having it on your phone that you use and
it's constantly trying to get into your
phone book and stuff like that like
that's the problem with otherwise like
the the access and the reach that you
can get there's no there's nothing bad
about that yeah to be honest with you I
wish that like uh Instagram and and
other social media uh sites would
be a little more forthcoming about how
you massage the algorithm and how you
make sure to get your stuff in because
if you go to tick tock and you go to the
the creators page or whatever they give
you it tells you how they give you a
list right down the list and you can you
can hit all the bullet points and you
will go from having no one to having
tons and tons of followers Tick Tock is
the only platform where you can gain
hundreds of thousands of followers in
less than 24 hours that's insane it
gives me so many people I can't I don't
know if it's real or not I don't think
it is sorry for over here I don't think
I don't think yeah I would not be
surprised if they're shoving AI
followers down your throat would make
Americans think they're getting
something out of it we've talked about
it before the way the way you start a
social media Network anyone can do this
right now start start a social media
Network
put out advertisements to uh you know a
certain age a younger age demographic 18
year olds when they sign up start giving
them followers rather quickly fake ones
and they feel like they're getting
social a dopamine hit right over and
over again when they post you give them
more likes then what happens is 18 year
old kid who's a freshman in college or
senior in high school goes to his
friends and goes I'm on labonte.com and
I've already got 10 000 followers and
they're like you have 10 000 followers
which you're on that stupid old school
YouTube I'm on labonte.com and then all
of a sudden these other kids are like I
want to get followers too and they all
start signing up all their followers are
fake but this attracts everyone to the
platform exactly so I don't believe tick
tock's real at this point maybe to a
certain degree but I still think you
know I'll just put it this way I they
they in my opinion there's a strong
likelihood that they did something that
effect oh absolutely I mean I got it I
remember one of my first videos ever was
like a million likes it wasn't it wasn't
it two different apps before it was
called like musically and like Lively or
something yeah yeah well when it used to
be a dancing app musically it was like a
lip syncing dancing app yeah they merged
two apps and turn it into Tick Tock did
you get paid on Tick Tock you can for
Creator funds but only if you tow the
lines and you're making dancing tick
tocks you know as a political
commentator you're not getting paid for
tickets so your your first video went
viral my first very video it was when I
was painting murals when I was doing
activism before journalism got over a
million likes how soon how fast that was
within four days it was insane and I
went over from I mean I think I had a
hundred thousand plus followers after
just one video and then every single
video I posted after that well over I
mean a million views it was you know
there was good engagement but you don't
know if that's real or fake or not at
the same time so there were two apps
Tick Tock did launch and there was also
musically they bought musically and then
merged it in and then got rid of
musically musically was the lip syncing
app yep I knew people who had accounts
and they were telling me how I got to
get on the platform because it was way
better and they have hundreds of
thousands of followers or one person was
like I have a million followers and I
was like let me pull up the app and I
pulled it up and it was like all the
comments were just like sweet rad nice
the most automated responses ever and I
was like I don't think you don't have
that many at all but you know the thing
is
they don't care all they want to do is
go to advertisers and be able to say
hey look they may be lying I'm not going
to say it I'm not going to accuse anyone
committing of committing a crime then
these these creators and influencers can
go to ad agencies and say I get a
billion views per month yep and they'll
be like wow what do you want and that's
it and you get money that could be a
scandal that's uncovered later where
we're like wow like yeah I'll tell you
about a meeting I had uh with Discovery
in uh Discovery Channel in San Francisco
where we sat down and this is probably
10 years ago this is probably eight
years ago
and they said what do you think about
Facebook yes it's probably about nine
eight or nine years ago what do you
think about Facebook videos versus
YouTube and I said YouTube is clearly
where it's at in terms of cultural
influence this is a decade ago by mind
what mind you and then the one guy is
one guy goes yeah but on Facebook we're
getting 10 times the views
and I'm like
are you really getting the views
rolling past the video and it's adding
to the count whereas YouTube is someone
actually watches the video and it shows
you the average watch time in a much
more detail in this lunch it was more
than just Discovery I can't remember who
said it it's been like a decade but
someone said something like
you know what ultimately doesn't matter
because these are the numbers we deliver
to advertisers yep and so they were like
let's just go to the advertisers and say
we got a hundred million views and I
think there's a lawsuit over this
because uh advertisers were advertisers
were buying view on Facebook views on
Facebook for these videos they were
buying Impressions and they weren't
getting delivered anything legitimate
I want like on YouTube all my
subscribers I want a button that will
let me clear anyone that subscribed me
that hasn't logged into YouTube in the
last year I want them removed I don't
want those numbers I want real numbers
even if it's less yo Ronnie said that
men can't have a period and that's why
he lost his Tick Tock wow
honestly worth it worth it yeah because
he's totally telling the truth when I
got into mines we started building free
software I became a bit of a zealot like
I'm just going to stop using the
proprietary crap I'm gonna stop using
YouTube stop using Twitter stop using
Facebook and Bill the CEO of Mines
convinced me like just keep using that
stuff it's it feels dirty but like it's
market research so maybe there's an
argument to use tick tock I just feel
like I'll get banned within you know a
month oh you will talk about Free Speech
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
that thanks for hanging out and we'll
see you all next time